Se vacciner, c'est un choix personnel, ça doit pas être obligatoire.
Alors en fait, c'est pas si simple que ça. Quand on se fait vacciner,
c'est pour éviter d'attraper une maladie
et on sait que déjà ça s'est compliqué pour pas mal de gens parce que ça revient à prendre des médicaments pour une maladie qu'on
n'a pas, pour pas l'avoir justement ça s'appelle de la prévention
On a du mal avec la prévention: bien manger, pas fumer, pas trop boire, pas rouler trop vite,
on a du mal. Mais se faire vacciner contre une maladie, c'est aussi
éviter de la transmettre et dans le cas de certaines maladies, ça veut dire éviter une épidémie et tous les problèmes qui vont avec
genre des handicaps
ou la mort. Et pour être sûr d'éviter une épidémie il faut que
suffisamment de personnes soient vaccinés, sinon ça marche pas et aujourd'hui les seules maladies pour lesquelles on arrive à 95 % de personnes vaccinées
c'est celles pour lesquelles la vaccination est déjà obligatoire.
ça, ça s'appelle la santé publique
et c'est fait pour protéger tout le monde et notamment ceux qui peuvent pas se faire vacciner parce qu'ils ont une contre-indication médicale.
C'est un acte citoyen en fait, la société, la communauté, elle te protège avec la sécu et plein d'autres trucs
tu te protèges et tu protèges la communauté, donc c'est pas juste une histoire personnelle.